[Applaudissements]
il est laurent fabius
regardez la réponse de la bile à ça
c'était un gros fous rires laurent
fabius il est ministre de quoi et du
poisson du poisson avec laurent findus
[Applaudissements]
oui
ici les enfants pleurent dans la musique
la belle aurait valu en france par
je fais
[Applaudissements]
ça va il aura une à bilin et nabi et
jean pierre du mont royal
ça va ça va ah ouais ça va trop trop de
là vous voulez le mental la vôtre
c'est pas noir je le trouve trop shoot
ressurgit ouais il est vraiment trop
mignon j'ai des t-shirts jacques chirac
gros bras sur la vie de ma mère c'est
vrai oui des t-shirt i love jack
queyranne mais j'aime ce soit mais là ça
se vend ça c'est franchement c'est voilà
j'aime trop jacques chirac et je la
rembourse pas le verra jamais alors
c'est vrai miège aurions aussi jacques
chirac nous regarde
franchement si jacques chirac vous nous
voir on va regarder parce que je voulais
je voulais te dire vont vous dire te
dire un truc c'est vrai c'est une
demande en mariage
non simplement je voulais juste te dire
que voilà merci de m'avoir j'ai pas je
crois qu'il y avait un cadeau au moins
un truc comme ça non j'espère avoir
soutenu pendant pendant tout ce temps et
que malgré que ce soit pour la télé ou
pas pour la télé de pâma avoir lâché
c'est tout simple
[Applaudissements]